the dot plot shows the number of hours
of daily driving time for 14 school bus
drivers each dot represents a driver so
for example one driver drives one hour a
day two drivers drive two hours a day
one driver drives three hours a day it
looks like there's five drivers that
drive seven hours a day which of the
following is the closest closest
estimate to the percentile rank for the
driver with a daily driving time of six
hours and then they give us some choices
which of the following is the closest
estimate to the percentile rank for the
driver with the daily driving time of
six hours so pause the video and see if
you can figure out which of these
percentiles is the closest estimate to
the percentile rank of a driver with a
daily driving time of six hours looking
at this data right over here all right
now let's work through this together so
when you think about percentile you
really want to think about so we write
this down when we're talking about
percentile we're really saying the
percentage of the data that and there's
actually two ways that you could compute
it one is the percentage of the data
that is below the amount in question
amount in question the other possibility
is the percent of the data that is at or
below that is at or below the amount the
amount in question so if we look at this
right over here let's just figure out
how many data points what percentage of
the data points are below six daily is
six hours per day so let's see there are
I'm just going to count them one two
three four five six seven so seven of
the 14 are below six hours so we could
just say seven if we use this first
technique we would have seven of the
fourteen hour
oh six hours per day and so that would
get us a number fifty percent with that
that six hours is it the 50th percentile
if we want to say what percentage is at
that number below then we would also
count this one so we would say eight or
eight out of 14 eight out of 14 which is
the same thing as four out of seven and
if we want to write that as the decimal
let's see seven goes into four point
zero zero zero easy to estimate so seven
goes into forty five times 35 we
subtract we get a five bring down a zero
goes five times like it's just going to
be 0.5 repeating so 55 point five five
five five percent so either of these
would actually be a legitimate response
to the percentile rank for the driver
with a daily driving time of six hours
it depends on whether you include the
six hours or not so you could say either
the 50th percentile or the roughly the
55th well actually the 56th percentile
if you wanted to round to the nearest
percentile now if you look at these
choices here lucky for us there's only
one choice it's even that's reasonably
close to either one of those and that's
the 55th percentile it looks like the
people who wrote this question went with
the calculation of percentile where they
include the data point in question so
everything at six hours or less what
percentage of the total data is that